291 3 milliards d'euros c'est ce que
l'état a récolté l'an dernier tout
impôts confondus
parmi les contribuables les entreprises
et les citoyens français mais pas tous
moins de la moitié des foyers de
l'hexagone sont imposables
vous pouvez payer deux sortes d'impôts
l'impôt direct qui inclut la taxe sur la
valeur ajoutée ou tva et bien sûr
l'impôt indirect incluant notamment
l'impôt sur le revenu la france est
championne du monde en matière de
prélèvements obligatoires mais également
en matière de dépenses publiques pour
exemple sur 100 euros d'impôts elle est
obligée d'emprunter 5 euros à l'union
européenne
et ce sans parler des intérêts mais
alors que fait l'état de notre argent
sur cette base de 100 euros 55 sont
consacrés à financer les retraites la
santé ou encore la sécurité sociale et
l'éducation soit plus de la moitié de
cette somme le reste eh bien il est
réparti entre la défense la justice ou
encore les infrastructures est loin
derrière on retrouve les secteurs tels
que la culture le logement ou encore la
transition écologique
la question de l'impôt sur le revenu
cristallise les tensions sociales et on
a pu le voir avec la crise des gilets
jaunes en dix ans son montant a augmenté
de 54% et vu la dégradation des services
publics en france les contribuables
n'ont vraiment pas l'impression d'en
avoir pour leur argent